the Village People have sent a cease and
desist letter to the failed former
president Donald J Trump you might know
if you ever watched the Trump rallies
that Trump regularly plays The Village
people's YMCA at the end of rallies and
as is the case with many of these
artists they've not been asked nor have
they given permission or would they give
permission for uh particularly
outrageous radical elected officials to
use their songs we've been wondering
about this with the Village People for a
long time and it has now all come to a
head the Village People telling Trump
don't use our song and I have to tell
you it makes perfect sense